hi i'm merle i am a tasty producer in
new york and today i'm going to tell you
why i started tasty veg
okay so this first video was one of the
ones that i was experimenting with when
i first started doing vegetarian content
this one was tricky but once you get the
hang of the cutting motion it's super
super simple my approach to this was to
just pick one vegetable at a time and
then see how many different ways i could
cook it or bake it and i was focusing on
potatoes and i found out that this is
actually a really popular street food
all over the world so i think that lent
itself to the success of the video a lot
of people be like i've seen this in my
city or i've seen this in japan or i've
seen this in mexico
this video is different because you
wouldn't look at this and be like oh
that's a vegetarian video you would just
be like oh that's so cool i want to try
that i bet you i could do that since it
did so well it caught my boss's
attention and he was like wow maybe it
is actually possible for you to do
plant-based food and it can go viral
after the success of the tornado potato
and a handful of other vegetarian videos
i made for tasty i was allowed to start
the tasty vegetarian page just kind of
as an experiment to see how vegetarian
content can work and if our audience was
large enough to handle its own page of
just that content so about a month into
starting the tasty vegetarian page i had
the idea to make a video about how you
could regrow your own fruits at home the
idea behind this was that you could save
money i was pretty sure a lot of people
didn't even know you could regrow your
own food and it seemed like a good use
for kitchen scraps so i dove into this
project and it ended up paying off
tenfold it's by far my most successful
video probably the one i've put the most
love into i was still relatively new as
a producer when i made this video but i
just dove into this project because i
was so excited about it so i had the
whole thing shot three weeks into all my
hard work and then i submitted it for
notes and i got the feedback that i
should have gone through research first
because we needed to make sure the stuff
i was putting out to the world was
actually true so
i ended up having to wait an additional
two and a half weeks before we could
actually publish this video i think one
reason you'd want to regrow your own
fruit is because you more than likely
have at least one of these things in
your house as it is and you're gonna
throw the scraps away anyway so why not
make the scraps work for you and you
might be able to save a little bit of
money down the road i mean if you buy
something at a store and then you find
out that by buying that it can then make
another one for free it just sounds like
a genius idea to me not to mention you
actually know where your food is coming
from so there's the benefit of your
confidence in how healthy this actually
is for you and where your food is coming
from and whether or not you've used
pesticides the other really cool thing
and another reason you might want to try
regrowing your own fruit is that you can
do it pretty much in any sized apartment
or house in anywhere in the world so
there's no reason not to try it you'll
save money and it's fun so after this
video was published i was looking
through the comments and i saw all these
people telling me like there's no way
this works i'm sure you guys are faking
this but meanwhile i'd spent three weeks
running to flower shops and trying to
make this video happen
and then i have people like alvin at
work saying why would you even do this
it's not even a tasty video but then the
video blew up and i saw people
commenting pictures of their own regrown
gardens and all these positive comments
and it ended up being completely worth
it it's my favorite video
so you gotta work for the things you
love
well this pancake video was part of a
challenge we did to make a week of vegan
content through that week i actually
started to get interested in veganism
myself one of my goals is to make food
that's good first and vegan second and
these pancakes accomplish that in going
vegan i don't want to feel like i can't
eat the things i love and pancakes were
my favorite breakfast growing up and
they still are and so i just wanted to
make vegan pancakes that were just as
delicious fluffiness is important for
them to be delicious my goal with
veganism and my goal with making vegan
content is to just show people that it
doesn't have to be scary it doesn't have
to be bland and it doesn't have to be
hard but i will say i don't think you
need to be 100 vegan i think baby steps
and like you know don't feel guilty
about wanting to eat cheese cheese is
delicious just do any little bit that
you can i don't want anyone saying that
you're a horrible person just because
you're not vegan i want to show you a
vegan recipe that you don't want to pass
up on and then maybe from there on
forward you'll elect to eat vegan food
just because you want to doesn't have to
be every meal it could be one meal a
week one meal a month it could be one
meal a year i just think it's important
to try new things
one way that i come up with videos for
tasty vegetarian is that i'll look back
at what we've done in the past and see
what's done really well and then i'll
try to make a vegetarian version of that
so back in the day alvin made this one
pot swedish meatballs video that
absolutely killed i have to give it to
him and i was like okay alvin i'm gonna
make that dish but i'm gonna make it
vegan and it's gonna be just as
delicious something that i hope can
change
is that people will stop judging other
people for what they eat in the
decisions that they make about their
diet and instead start asking questions
and realize we're all doing our best
just because it's different doesn't mean
it's bad i was very happy with how these
swedish meatballs turned out if you're
gonna ask me if they tasted exactly like
meatballs like real meatballs with meat
of course not because they're not meat
however i can tell you they capture a
lot of the same savory notes and if
you're nostalgic for them and you miss
them and you don't eat meat they will
absolutely do the trick
the vegan cinnamon rolls were another
video that i made during our vegan week
sprint and the ideation was the same for
these i wanted to take a past hit video
from tasty and make it vegan two and a
half years ago i was hired at buzzfeed i
started as an intern as many of us do
and i was actually making food
pretty much from day one i worked really
really really hard for six months and
finally i was given the opportunity to
come on to the tasty team before tasty
there was buzzfeed food and i was making
videos for them but then tasty came
about and was a huge success and i was
lucky enough to jump on the team
buzzfeed is my first job it's the only
full-time job i've ever had and before i
came here i took a year and a half off
to go home and kind of figure out what i
wanted to do when i got to new york i
didn't have too much of a plan i just
applied to buzzfeed online and a day
after i moved to new york without any
real plan or any job i got a call saying
that they were interested in doing an
interview with me for an internship
position i was so excited i remember
calling my mom and my entire family and
kind of freaking out so six months after
i was hired as an intern i was offered a
full-time position with tasty and i was
a tasty producer i gladly accepted and
then basically turned around and said
okay well now i'm gonna be vegetarian
and i don't want to use any meat in any
of my videos i was really nervous at
first and wasn't sure how they were
going to take that but to my surprise
they were very open and they were very
accepting of my choice they were up for
the challenge they were like okay if you
can make vegetarian tasty videos work go
for it and i did this whole experience
has been incredibly humbling but also
it's given me the opportunity to really
trust my instinct and to believe that
other people will feel the same way that
i do and to see it as a success has
meant more to me than you can even
imagine i feel really good about what i
do and i'm lucky enough to enjoy going
to work every day and feel like i'm
doing a little bit of good for the world
because i've had the opportunity to take
something that i'm super passionate
about and make it approachable and easy
for people all over the world so i
really don't know anyone with a cooler
job than mine oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you